>> THIS PRISON HAD PLENTY.
SECURITY ABOVE THE GROUND.
WAYS OF BLOCKING CELL PHONE
SIGNALS.
THEY HAD HEAVILY ARMORED
VEHICLES TO REPULSE ANY GROUND
ASSAULT.
THEY HAD THREE FOOT THICK WOLVES
SO ROCKETS COULD NOT BREAK IN.
AND THROUGH ALL OF THAT, EL
CHAPO FOUND A WAY TO BURROW OUT
UNDER THE NOSES OF MEXICAN
AUTHORITIES AND GET TO THIS
FREEDOM TUNNEL OFF IN THE
DISTANCE HERE.
AND GO COMPLETELY FREE.
HOW DID HE MANAGE TO DO THAT?
WELL, FIRST OF ALL HE TAPPED
INTO THE EXPERTISE OF HIS GANG.
WHICH HAS BEEN KNOWN TO BUILD
ALL SORTS OF TUNNELS FOR
TRANSPORTING DRUGS AND ELUDING
ENEMIES.
THEY STARTED BENEATH A SHOWER.
ONE OF THE FEW PLACES WHERE HE
WASN'T BEING MONITORED BY VIDEO
24 HOURS A DAY.
HE WENT 33 FEET STRAIGHT DOWN
AND THEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
DETAILS OF THIS TUNNEL YOU.
SEE AN ENGINEERING MARVEL.
THIS THING WAS 5 1/2 FEET TALL,
HIS HEIGHT.
2 1/2 FEET WIDE.
HE COULD SIMPLY WALK THROUGH IT.
IT WAS REINFORCED WITH WOOD TO
KEEP TRACK OF ALL THE STRUCTURAL
INTEGRITY, WHETHER OR NOT GROUND
WALT
WATER WAS SEEPING IN.
A LIGHTING SYSTEM.
SEE WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
A VENTILATION SYSTEM NO GASSES
THAT COULD OVERCOME ANYONE
THERE.
THEY HAD A TRACK ALONG THE
BOTTOM OF SO IT THEY COULD
TRANSPORT OUT ON SOME SORT OF
CART OR MOTORCYCLE.
NOT CLEAR WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IN THE END THIS
THING WAS A MILE LONG.
AND OVER THAT DISTANCE IT COULD
HAVE TAKEN A YEAR TO BUILD
EASILY.
AND YET, ONE OF THE MOST WANTED
DRUG DEALERS IN THE WORLD WAS
ABLE TO WALK OUT THERE IN TEN
MINUTES OR LESS.
>> TOM, WE HAVE COVERED DRUG
TUNNELS FROM MEXICO TO THE U.S.
I'VE BEEN INSIDE OF THEM.
WE HEARD OF NEW TECHNOLOGY TO
HELP FIND THE TUNNELS,000.
COULD THAT HAVE HELPED HERE?
>> YOU STOOD DOWN THERE, YOU
WONDER HOW COULD THEY NOT HEAR
THIS GOING ON?
I TALKED TO A GOPHYGEOPHYSICIST
MITER CORPORATION, CONTRACTING
WITH THE GOVERNMENT TO DEVELOP
BETTER SYSTEM.
SHE TOLD ME IT IS JUST NOT THAT
GOOD YET.
A DIFFICULT TASK.
YOU ARE THREE STORIES DOWN.
THOUGH YOU HAVE DEVICES
LISTENING FOR DIGGING.
MAYBE FRTRYING TO MEASURE
ANOMALIES IN THE EARTH.
THEY HAVE TO BE REALLY CLOSE
BEFORE THEY CAN TELL SOMETHING
IS GOING ON HERE.
BIGGER QUESTION THOUGH IS HOW
COME NOBODY NOTICED THE DIRT.
WE SAID THIS IS A MILE LONG
HERE.
THINK ABUT OUT THIS.
A MILE LONG.
TAKING A LOT OF DIRT AWAY.
IN FACT MORE THAN 200 BIG
DUMPTRUCKS FULL.
HARD TO IMAGINE, FOR ALL